what is a Levine's test Levine's test
tests the hypothesis that the variances
are equal in different groups
the aim is to determine whether the
variances in different groups are
significantly different from each other
the hypotheses for Levine's test are as
follows the null hypothesis is the
variances of the groups are equal and
the alternative hypothesis is at least
one of the groups has a different
variance
when is Levine's test most commonly used
Levine's test is most often used to test
assumptions for another hypothesis test
what does that mean let's say your
hypothesis is there is a difference
between two medications in terms of
perceived pain relief to test this
hypothesis you've collected data now to
test the hypothesis based on your data
you use a hypothesis test such as a
t-test many hypothesis tests have the
assumption that the variances in each
group are equal and this is where
Levine's test comes in it tells us
whether this assumption is fulfilled or
not how is a Levine's test calculated
here's an example we want to know if
there is a significant difference in
variance between these groups first we
simply calculate the mean of each group
then we subtract the respective group
mean from each person the amount of each
value is now formed so that the negative
values become positive from these new
values the group mean can now be
calculated again the larger the group
mean the greater the variance within
each group
thus there is a smaller variance in this
group than in that group
in addition we can calculate the total
mean value
now we can calculate the square
deviations of the group means from the
overall mean and sum them up
and then we can calculate the square
deviation of the individual values from
the respective group mean and add them
up
we can now compare the two calculated
sums and that is exactly what Levine's
test does
the test statistic of Levine's test is
obtained with this equation
n is the number of cases and I the
number of cases in the I's group set I
is the mean value of the ice group
set is the overall average
set i j is the respective value in the
groups and K is the number of groups
the calculated test statistic L is equal
to the S statistic therefore with the F
value and the degrees of freedom the
p-value can be calculated
the degrees of freedom result with
number of groups minus one and number of
cases minus number of groups if the
p-value is greater than 0.05 the null
hypothesis that the variances are equal
is not rejected thus equality of
variance can be assumed if you use data
Tab and calculate an analysis of
variance you can find Levine's test
under test assumptions
in an independent t-test
you will find Levine's test at the
bottom of the results
if equality of variance is not given you
can use the t-test for unequal variance
thanks for watching and I hope you
enjoyed the video